so I don't work on refugees specifically
I work on migration writ large and my my
contribution here tonight is maybe to
frame this question around what we
understand the refugee crisis to be and
how we define or distinguish rather
refugees from migrants so the concept of
a refugee is actually a legal concept
that emerged in the immediate post-war
years the convention was ratified in
1951 and it is a distinction that grew
out of the failure of European countries
primarily to deal with the World War Two
refugees the massive movement of people
who had been displaced by this
cataclysmic event this is the
distinction that we still use and we
haven't deployed it or thought through
it as deliberately as we've been
thinking about it over the past five
years because the the major refugee
crises were the major forced
displacement of people have been in
areas that have received far less
coverage in the US and in Europe so
primarily sub-saharan Africa and with
internal displacement in sub-saharan
Africa and Latin America Colombia
primarily Colombia has a huge internally
displaced persons problem in fact it was
interesting in your map that the the
causes for displacement were all natural
disasters but in fact in Colombia that
the major cause of displacement is
actually violence and civil war so my
understanding is that it might be
helpful to present a little bit of the
long now yes well I was always welcome
right so this notion is a is a notion
that emerged right after the world after
world war 2 and for the u.s. the North
Atlantic region and Europe migration has
been for the most part the steady
regulated flow of people it's been there
have been labor movement Accords right
so Europe imported guest workers from
north
turkey the u.s. signed the bracero
program with Mexico and regulated flows
that had informal undocumented
components but no big spikes the big
spike is what has drawn our attention
the big spike to Europe has drawn our
attention to the refugee crisis today
Lebanon and Turkey and Jordan have
experienced these flows and big numbers
really since the beginning of the civil
war the u.s. in particular has in its
history and I know there's an American
historian and audience here so I may
stand corrected but in its history the
US has experienced these big spikes and
has not had the same kind of anxiety
around these big spikes in the past so
one example that for me is very poignant
is the Irish potato famine
so Ireland between 1930 1847 and which
was the year the first year of the
famine and 1851 lost 1.5 million people
and it was a population in the census
but the last census before the famine
listed the population of Ireland and
eight million so that that's an
equivalent number to the kind of
displacement proportionally that you see
from Syria today and most of the so a
huge number of Irish ended up on in New
York in Boston in Philadelphia and in
Montreal Toronto they were they traveled
across the Atlantic in slave ships that
had been repurposed for the movement of
Irish immigrants and Manhattan which in
1847 had a population of 300,000
received 200,000 people in two years and
its population grew by 1/4 so did sort
of the population of Boston Philadelphia
one more city that I'm forgetting
Baltimore maybe no Chicago didn't get a
lot of Irish they did they got a lot of
Germans who move Midwest to the Midwest
but these populations were not tagged as
refugees they were just seen as migrants
on the cities that received them absorb
them we didn't we didn't tag them
differently that the the tagging of
refugees as distinct from migrants is a
new phenomenon as is the sense that the
cities in Europe and North America
cannot absorb them we have in the past
and it wasn't as traumatic as one might
think
right so it shaped our understandings of
things like infrastructure and poverty
but basically basically we have in the
past had this capacity and it's this new
tagging that has transformed our vision
of what we can absorb and what we can
absorb and
[Music]
you